[Musique]
le 8 mars c'est le jour du prix célimène
à la villa du département
mais déjà certains regards observe
l'exposition qui sera dévoilé dans la
soirée
l'espionné koala une soirée feutrée pour
célébrer les femmes artistes amateurs
qui n'ont jamais eu l'occasion de faire
connaître leur travail et c'est une
artiste des seychelles qui a présidé
cette édition et safran qui est très
original
j'ai été très touché ma par exemple pas
avec l'histoire des celi même les fans
ici sont très motivés même s'ils n'ont
pas eu ma
une éducation la informelle mais ma la
façon que le parti dans cette expo
j'étais très touché par ça ce sont les
collégiens qui ont ouvert la remise de
prix cette classe pétillante remporte le
prix célimène parmi sept collèges on lit
ce soir nous sommes à aspirer du tapis
mendiant de grands de nos grands-mères
en utilisant du papier et du tissu de
forme en forme de rosace de tout colle
de toutes les couleurs enfin de réaliser
la chevelure qui représente la 10e
l'addip la navette à vous hong kong
durant toutes vos études durant toute
votre vie
bravo nous a dit qu'il faut familles du
département il y aura de grands
personnages et du coup on se fait tous
vents il avait raison
[Musique]
les émotions se sont succédé chacune
fier de son armée pas habitués au devant
de la scène oui c'est vrai mes propos et
peut-être ça va être le début d'une
exposition très peut-être que j'expose
parce que j'ai une demi pièces de
tableau qui remplit donc mon mari a dit
ferait peut-être vider la maison et
voilà que c'est très contente car c'est
la preuve que je participe à un concours
donc je suis plutôt ravis
de pouvoir pas que cette oeuvre est
autant plus est contente aussi que la
photographie argentique puisse exister
au final c'est madame guylaine lorraine
qui recevra premier 2019 et sa bière
comme ça c'est une espèce
c'est une inspiration tout naturellement
la créativité féminine qui s'exposent
devant le lieu ici c'est sûr ce sont ses
talents d'artiste et la femme
réunionnaise a beaucoup à nous dire à
travers les autres
je remercie tout le monde m'avait
encouragé il a par mireille chevet voilà
le féliciter
saveurs pc je pense que ça m'encourage à
continuer à continuer à progresser
elle a fait deux tués
ses oeuvres sont visibles jusqu'au 22
mars 2019 à la villa du département
[Musique]
ah ah